hey welcome to the Reuben report I'm the
guy that told Obama to use an orange
line instead of a red line dave rubin
I've got Jackie Geary and Ben mankiewicz
with me the first time ever by the way
that we've had a guest bring a computer
to the desk I'm a little nervous about
this Ben I shake things up hema yeah I
did it on I did it a match game in 1979
and jeanne was queasy it said it but it
worked out well alright well we have
computers and we have plenty of
information for you we're going to start
off with Syria I thought the war was
going to start last week they've given
us a little extra time here as we know
Obama is going to Congress right now
this thing is going to happen there's
absolutely no doubt about it John Kerry
was speaking to the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee yesterday I think
it's kind of funny that we've decided
that somehow going to a group of people
whose approval rating is fifteen percent
is what's going to decide whether we're
going to war or not we are going alright
so let's start though with Nancy Pelosi
because she apparently gets her wartime
advice from her five-year-old grandson
I'll tell you this story and then I
really do have to go my five-year-old
grandson as I was leaving San Francisco
yesterday he said to me me me my name
Mimi
war with Syria are you yes war with
Syria no war with Syria no it's five
years old and Ward's thing more I mean
we're not drawing that war we're talking
about an action yes for Syrian no one's
here I said well what do you think he
said I think no war I said well I
generally agree with that but you know
they've killed hundreds of children
there they've killed hundreds of
children and he said five years old were
these children in the United States and
I said no but their children wherever
they are so I don't know what news he's
listening to or her position but even a
five-year-old child has to you know with
the wisdom of our interests who had it
affect our interest so it affects our
interest because it was a again outside
the circle civilized behavior was
humanity drew a line decades ago that I
think if we ignore we do so to the peril
of many other people through food cetera
okay so we all get it she's trying to be
cute there and humanized this thing
except it seems to me that her
grandchild actually has more of a sound
foreign policy then she does because her
grandson said are they American implying
if they're not American then maybe we
shouldn't do this which seems to be
something that Nancy Pelosi pretty much
believed until this war what is the
Botox going straight to her brain I
guess that's really the way to start
this essentially like me me no me me
yeah the kids are not they are not
United States citizens don't do it Mimi
and she was like oh kids isn't that
funny did she realize what the kid was
saying there cuz the go is making the
point they're not Americans don't do
don't do it the fact that the House
Democratic Leader missed the point of a
five year old story but I've year old
story was pretty clear right no war okay
I have a follow-up question cuz you
appear to be pro war yes are the kids
Americans no they're not and then she
turns that into so I think he sees the
world and how the world works people
involved rain tough days
what's up stuff I start saying words she
then relates it back to the red line
that the world has set and I don't know
if you guys saw this but just like an
hour ago Obama speaking and now he's
saying it's not his or he never meant
red line this is the world's red line is
there anything that's true anymore you
know we had a coup in Egypt a couple
weeks ago and they refuse to call it a
coup the red line is no longer a red
light is the bigger problem here that
this is now all about words we're not
even honest with the just the way we
word things no we're just we're just
going to use a lot of words and say
things and try to get out of having said
things and change what we said into
something else completely as a people we
spend far too much time worrying about
the words in the first place what
matters is the action what matters is
the policy it shouldn't matter whether
Obama said the red line of the world
said the red line or not just mean it's
useless because you say something
doesn't mean you have to do it later
right if I say to my girlfriend if you
ever uh you know if you ever above if
you ever sleep with somebody else I will
leave you and then it turns up no I
don't want to leave her we have a family
and like like what if I if I committed
some grave horrible error right but no I
get to make my decision then based on
the circumstances on the ground okay so
what would you say they just for the
record as I know she hasn't right now so
she's a bit of a [ __ ] yeah right wait
wait but so for all the people that are
saying well Obama set this red line and
it's not Obama's credibility on the line
it's the United States credibility you
just don't see that as a valid I think
that for this is a perfect example of
what we talked about far too much in the
rich world pon de tree uh-uh and in
general we talk about reputation and
sort of earning respect and doing damage
to your reputation and most of all
hypocrisy like the world is a
complicated place the Middle East is a
perfect example of that complication and
yeah maybe we took an action here we
didn't take an action air because
circumstances change they change every
day and the right thing on thursday may
have been a different thing on monday
yeah does it seem to you guys that this
is really not about Syria this is really
about Iran because it seems to me that
Syria was only doing stuff in their
borders they've already killed a hundred
thousand people which is pretty awful
that it's we're building this thing up
that killed them
in a cool way I old-fashioned a
conventional the classic way uh but that
it seems to me we were putting all these
destroyers in the Mediterranean uh
Russia's putting a bunch of destroyers
in the Suez Canal like this thing is
leading to that Obama really set a red
line that's important about Iran and the
nuke that this the chemical weapons they
may not be the real issue here I got ya
got it's certainly possible i mean i
think there are two big concerns i also
think that before we dismiss using
attacks on syria which I you know would
would rather we didn't but mostly
because I can't see how it no one has
yet unless you've read something that I
have not no one has made a case as to
why it will be affected other than we
have to do it if we don't do it it's
ineffective rather than here's what it's
going to do that's exactly I they said
yes but it does matter that even though
hundred thousand people have been killed
uh as you say in the classic way and
turner classic movies that approves of
the classic yeah yeah uh as long as they
kill them in black and white and uh we
like yeah and they're not that much
blood when they die we can't see if the
kids uh look at away but if the world
the world is made like these decisions
that the world makes about things like
chemical weapons that matter they do
matter and they broke that and I and
unlike I don't know about you guys but
unlike Iraq I don't really have any
doubt that this that this information is
seems incredibly I'm right the great did
this so I get that you have to do that I
get the feeling that you have to do
something right that there has to be
action taken and that we can't just say
those hundred thousand people who were
killed conventionally you know that's
bad but we don't take action but these
fourteen hundred and four hundred
children who were killed in the chemical
attack is different it is different how
you react to it obviously is incredibly
tricky so why do we have to do it every
time that's the part you know Obama has
been this big un guy and everything has
to go through the UN but he's now the
one that's exposed the UN for the total
fraud that it is because we can't get
anything done in the UN cuz of China and
Russia so why is it the US I don't know
that we're any better than Canada how
competitor doesn't feel they have to be
we've decided were the police somehow
and we're in charge of everything and I
think that's why a lot of countries are
annoyed by us you know do you
the polite term is just that we feel
like this is all our business yeah um
which yes it's horrible a terrific I'd
uh but I don't see what it's going to do
and nobody is coming up with any sort of
real plan that seems that will make any
difference it's just the John Kerry
threat of well if we don't then what